allez on y va une plantation symbolique
de ceps de vigne pour sceller le mariage
de toute la viticulture régionale
levine au pôle centre val de loire a
désormais sa maison 1500 m² de
laboratoires et de bureau sur le site du
lycée viticole d'amboise
tout ce qui y prend place existait déjà
l'intérêt est donc de mettre de la
cohésion dans la filière la nouveauté
c'est simplement d'avoir eu la
prétention collégialement pas seulement
l'ubs perché mais l'ensemble de la
filière s'organiser pour mutualiser les
travaux pour éviter à la fois des
doublons organiser le transfert des
connaissances auprès de nos structures
d'exploitation coopérative négoce mise
en marché et cette maison commune les
vignerons en attend un effet de levier
pour tous les dossiers qu'ils défendent
souvent dispersés chacun chez soi
désolé ça permet de voir de vrais
disques aucun talent je suis content
parce qu'il ya les élus qui entendent
enfin des discours qui remonte on espère
que
il ya une réelle cohésion avec la
scolarité et l'institut de recherche
et puis essayer de dynamiser
la victime s'en va le voir à ce niveau
là outre l'affichage de la force d'une
profession levine au pôle représente
aussi l'un des principaux centres de
recherche appliquée de la viticulture
française
on y travaille déjà sur des questions
spécifiques aux terroirs ligérien on
souhaite notamment proposé aux vignerons
l'élaboration de nouvelles cuvées
régionales les vins en fait en région
centre on a ensuite ils ont à souffrir
d'un manque une
de consommation plutôt sur les vins
rouges et on travaille donc avec eux sur
touraine amboise sur les propositions
d'un produit 100 % qu aujourd'hui s'en
fait quelques-uns l'objectif c'est de
pouvoir effectivement produire plus et
bien sûr la première question c'est
savoir en fait qu'elle typologie de
produits en offert en adéquation fait
avec le marché levine au col d'amboise
aura coûté au total 2 millions d'euros
les viticulteurs espère un rapide retour
sur investissement